When the Babylon Bee reported that
Congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
had appeared on The Price is Right, guessing that everything presented by host Drew Carey,
including world-class health care, costs nothing at all,
the prominent online fact-checking site, Snopes, assured readers that this didn't actually occur.
It labeled the story false, along with,
"Democrats demand that  Brett Kavanaugh submit to DNA tests to prove he's not actually Hitler."
and "CNN purchases industrial sized washing machine to spin news before publication."
And they fact check and say no, you know, we checked the record. CNN didn't buy a washing machine recently.
And so that was kind of bizarre. It does seem like they fact-check our ones that  target the left more often.
Kyle Mann is the editor-in-chief of the Christian satirical news site which has surged in popularity,
boasting about 10 million monthly page views just three years after its founding.
We don't necessarily target one side over the other, and we don't necessarily strive for balance.
We look to target whoever's being ridiculous, you know, on a given day.
There's plenty to go around. And there's plenty to go around on both sides.
Snopes defense for fact-checking satire is that a lot of people are misled by it,
and that they're  just trying to help people strengthen their media literacy skills.
Do you see that as legitimate and has that been consistent with your experience with Snopes?
We don't necessarily disagree with the idea of someone saying hey we're gonna fact-check a joke, you know,
or we're gonna fact-check this piece.
Because yeah sometimes there's a lot of people out there that don't recognize satire.
The real concern is that when we start looking at, you know, who is the fact checker?
Like who are these people that are supposed to be these objective fact checkers?
You know, and it's really concerning when someone sets themselves up and they say
whenever we say something is true you know we slap this green true label on it,
or we say it's false and we slapped this red false label.
And how do we know that that's accurate? You know, we've seen  ideological bias from Snopes in the past.
After Georgia lawmaker, Erika Thomas, retracted her claim
that someone had told her to go back to her country, the Bee published an article poking fun at the incident.
Again Snopes accused Mann and his colleagues of publishing fake news.
We even made a joke saying that she
went to Chick-Fil-A,
and the Chick-Fil-A worker says, "my pleasure" you know and she says, oh he told me to go back to my country.
We're known for our Chick-Fil-A jokes like that's one of our main things that we go back to.
They filed us under the category junk nudes, and said that we were trying to fan the flames of controversy.
And the ironic thing was they didn't even fact-check Erica Thomas's original claim,
but they fact checked I joke about it.
So that's when we start to be concerned about some kind of slant or bias.
Mann says that by mischaracterizing the Bee's content,
Snopes could have a negative impact on its traffic and revenue.
We've been threatened with demonetization and deplatforming from Facebook,
when they had a relationship with Snopes for fact checking.
So that's kind of concerning, when a lot of these social media sites are looking at how to squash fake news
and if we start to get lumped in with sites that are actually sharing fake news,
then it could be a big problem for
our platform and how we reach people.
Snopes, which didn't respond to Reasons
interview requests,
has said that a significant percentage of social media users mistake satire for real news.
But Mann says that when making this claim, Snope cited a methodologically flawed study,
In which participants were showed Babylon Bee headlines reworded and taken out of context.
A lot of times they missed the joke entirely.
They didn't even accurately represent what our joke was trying to say,
and just did a very literal interpretation of it,
and in that context I can understand why a lot of people were deceived.
Although the Babylon Bee is primarily concerned with making its readers laugh
man says that the site has a more serious mission too: uncovering truth
You can take satire and you can use it to divide
you can cut away what we believe is true or what believe is important from what's not important
and we see that in satire of politics, we see that in satire of of religion.
You know specifically when we when we do satire about the modern church we do satire about Christian living,
you know we can take a lot of these these sacred cows
that Christians have set up and just skewer 'em.
You know and obviously a lot
of people don't appreciate that
but we feel like it's a great weapon, it's a
great tool to kind of separate what's important from what's not
whether that's politics or our Christianity.
Mann says that while Snopes is wrong to treat the
Babylon be as a serious news source
the satirical site does seek to help readers
better understand the real world.
I'd like to say that the satire is not truth
but it's like truth adjacent
so you're creating this alternate world you're
creating this alternate reality.
It's almost a mirror that holds up this
reflection of our world.
And we can help draw people's world views and opinions
to a logical conclusion.
And then some people can look at a look at that and
maybe say 'whoa' you know,
'maybe my ideas do need to be thought out a little bit more'
and sometimes not, you know, sometimes people will just get a good laugh out of it
and that's ok with us too.